good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight for more than a month
mobs of violent crazy people have roamed
this country terrorizing citizens and
destroying things no one has stopped
them from doing that so they've
continued and they've become stronger
politicians now cower before the mob
corporate America mouths their slogans
the education cartel enforced on your
children enforces their demands police
officers emasculated and restrained
watch it all from the sidelines unable
to help for weeks we've asked who will
stand up for this country and the answer
we're learning is Americans Americans
will it's up to them small groups of
citizens are beginning to come forward
to defend their laws defend their
history and their culture and Tifa does
not own these things neither as black
lives matter they have no right to
destroy them in New York City over the
weekend a group of citizens gathered to
defend a statue of Teddy Roosevelt Teddy
Roosevelt was the most popular history
president in the history of this nation
that's partly because he was a sterling
moral example and Tifa wants him erased
local officials have said they will
comply with that demand no one asked the
public what the public thinks of this
our leaders don't care what they think
this group decided to be heard
that's the New York we love is that the
best you got yes actually it is
the best they've got tear off the masks
turn down the volume and you see it very
clearly the mob is not fearsome it's
pathetic
these are pampered children play acting
at revolution they are cowards that's
why they move in packs they have no
skills all they can do is destroy the
closer you get to him the clearer all of
that is they're trying to find this as a
racial issue this is not about race
anymore it never really was this is
about taking a pot being the fabric of
America well exactly this is not about
racial justice it never was about racial
justice that's obvious to the rest of us
now the president understands it too
last week he issued an executive order
to protect our monuments from the mob
and Saturday the Department of Justice
charged for people with destruction of
federal property for vandalizing
monuments right across from the White
House
federal park police posted 15 wanted
posters online the president retweeted
them oh but the overpaid corporate
revolutionaries on cable news were
outraged by that enforcing the law
enforcing law is racist they lectured us
MSNBC anchors enjoy seeing statues
topple as they glide by in their car
services it makes them feel alive in
another sign of where his priorities are
during this time the President signed a
new executive order yesterday centered
on protecting monuments memorials and
statues not people so he threatens
prison terms he threatened retribution
he defends statues he ignores the
substance of the message and wholly
misses the mark
president Trump signed an executive
order about the protests
but not to protect people dying at the
hands of the state instead he signed an
order that denounced protesters who
vandalize civil war monuments protecting
statues while real people suffer and
some died they're such liars civil war
monuments they're taking down statues
for Abraham Lincoln but did you catch
the last line well real people suffer
well Patricia and Mark McCloskey are
real people they live in st. Louis as
their City degraded and fell apart
around them became dirty and dangerous
over the last decades they did not flee
to the suburbs many of their neighbors
did but they stayed in their home
they've been in the same home for 32
years they've rebuilt it entirely slowly
painstakingly they love it on Sunday the
McCloskey sat in their backyard together
having dinner suddenly as they ate a mob
of hundreds of screaming people
destroyed a wrought iron gate with a no
trespassing sign on it and came pouring
in moving toward them quickly
McCluskey's were terrified they'd
watched his mobs looted and burned and
assaulted citizens around the country
this mob was clearly intent on violence
they said so when Mark McCluskey told
them to leave the mob threatened to
murder him and his wife then they
threatened to kill the family's dog
panicked the McCluskey's called the
police then they called the neighborhood
security patrol but no one came they had
no choice to protect themselves they
went inside and got there yes legally
registered firearms
[Applause]
it worked
met finally by citizens who dared defend
himself the mob retreated and melted
away but the terror did not end the
sight of ordinary Americans standing up
for themselves and their home enraged
our professional class and they
immediately put the McCluskey's name and
their home address all over the Internet
threats poured in mark McCloskey spent
last night boarding up his office
downtown he had no choice
still no one stepped forward to protect
the McCluskey's not one person amazingly
Missouri has a Republican governor
former sheriff called Mike parson the
governor parson did not stand state
troopers to defend the McCluskey's from
antifa
governor parson didn't even call the
McCluskey's there's a lot he could have
done the governor could have announced
that as long as he runs the state no
citizen will be prosecuted for
exercising the most basic of all rights
the right of self-defense against the
mob but the governor didn't do that in
fact he did nothing and so sensing they
were completely undefended that jackals
descended on the McCluskey's st. Louis's
District Attorney
a woman called Kim Gardner announced
that she was considering filing criminal
charges against the McCluskey's for
resisting the mob a mob that was
threatening to murder them
Gardner vowed to quote use the full
power of Missouri law to hold the
McCluskey's accountable for the crime of
self-defense not the full power to
defend them against people who are
threatening to kill them but the full
power to crushed them for resisting the
media meanwhile immediately said about
trying to show the McCluskey's were
racists here's how the Washington Post
framed this story quote as the peaceful
crowd of about 500 walked along a
private gated street a white couple who
emerged from a marble mansion had
something else in mind the New York
Times agreed this was definitely a hate
crime quote President Trump on Monday
morning retweeted a video of a white man
and woman brandishing a semi-automatic
rifle and a handgun at
peaceful black protestors almost every
word a lie
in fact the mob was not quote black
whatever that means and it definitely
wasn't peaceful it was murderous in
order to anyone explain what the
McCluskey's race had to do with anything
a white man a white couple okay they are
so what why is that relevant why is it
ever relevant in a situation like this
it's not but again no one bothered to
explain online the mobs digital enablers
took the bait they know what to do
time to hate the McCluskey's a longtime
libertarian activist in Washington
called Jerry Taylor immediately tweeted
this quote if I were in that March and
these racist lunatics were waving guns
at me I'd like to think I'd rush them
and beat their brains in and I wouldn't
apologize for it for one goddamn second
end quote
Jerry tailored by the way isn't some
lone lunatic he runs a think tank in
Washington it's called the Niskanen
Center and it here was Jerry Taylor
libertarian and good standing
encouraging brutal violence against
strangers for defending themselves
no one even seemed to notice nobody
cared the message to everyone else was
crystal clear the mob is in charge their
power cannot be curbed don't even
consider defending yourself
self defense is racist Michigan Governor
Gretchen Whitmer all but said that out
loud today
Whitmer demanded that her state may make
quote racially motivated 911 calls a
hate crime making fit false 9-1-1 calls
is already at prime in the state of
michigan so will be the purpose of this
order you know the answer fear the mob
wants the power to destroy anyone who
wants police protection from quote
mostly peaceful protests
it's an impediment to their power so
Gretchen Whitmer is trying to sweep it
away you can see exactly what's coming
it's obvious what they're planning
what's fasting is the people doing this
know it too they know the consequences
of these plans and they don't plan to
live with those consequences on Friday
the Minneapolis City Council voted
unanimously to abolish their city's
police department a number of them
explained why they were voting this way
watch and now is the time
for us as a city to start paying the
community members who have been doing
this work for decades and need to get
paid all that money has been going into
the police department and what we have
we gotten in return pain trauma and
hurts we will be taking intermediate
steps towards ending the MPD through the
budget process showing up as a person
who believes that we should and can
abolish our current Minneapolis police
system those were awfully emphatic
statements who it might be easy to be
misled by them the Minneapolis City
Council isn't actually opposed to armed
protection they're opposed to you having
it they're opposed to the police
protecting your family and your homes
but they're not opposed to protecting
themselves and that's why the three
Minneapolis city councilmen you just saw
requested and received taxpayer-funded
security guards you pay for them they
stand outside their homes of course they
did that they don't want to get hurt